– Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Surfshark, más sobre esto en un momento. –
En el campo de batalla, la guerra de Ucrania ha
sido un gran fracaso para Rusia. Sin embargo,
esta no es la única mala noticia
político-militar que ha sufrido el Kremlin.
Uno de los grandes argumentos que Moscú
utilizó para intentar justificar su atroz
invasión fue la de impedir a toda costa que la
OTAN continuara expandiéndose hacia el este.
Según el gobierno ruso, esto suponía para
ellos un riesgo absolutamente inaceptable.
Hoy, queridos amigos, amigas, las
cosas han dado un giro de 180 grados.
La invasión de Ucrania hizo que países
como Finlandia o Suecia se plantearan
cambiar su estatus. Si hasta ahora habían
ido por libres, la invasión les convenció
de que eso ya no era nada recomendable.
Tenían sí o sí que sumarse a la OTAN.
En abril del 2023 lo hizo Finlandia.
Sin embargo, Suecia lo ha tenido
mucho más difícil… Hasta ahora.
Finalmente, y pese a todos los tira
y afloja que veremos en este vídeo,
Suecia se convertirá en el trigesimosegundo
miembro de la Alianza Atlántica.
Y, ojo, porque esto no es algo que la
haga ninguna gracia a Rusia. De hecho,
llevan años diciendo y haciendo
cosas como estas. Fijaos.
N1(18 de junio de 2015: Embajador
ruso: “Si Suecia se une a la OTAN,
habrá 'consecuencias'. Putin señaló que habrá
consecuencias, que Rusia tendrá que recurrir
a una respuesta de tipo militar y reorientar
nuestras tropas y misiles”. Business Insider)
N2 (4 de febrero de 2016: Rusia simuló un ataque
nuclear contra Suecia, admite la OTAN: Telegraph)
Con una extensión de unos 450.000
km² y casi 11 millones de habitantes,
Suecia es el tercer país más extenso de toda la
Unión Europea y la gran potencia escandinava.
La pregunta es, ¿por qué Suecia preocupa
tanto al Kremlin? ¿Qué supone exactamente
para la OTAN la inclusión de este
país? ¿Realmente esto es algo que
puede preocuparle a Rusia? ¿Qué es
lo que cambiará a partir de ahora?
Pues en este vídeo vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas. Y para entender
bien toda esta historia lo primero
será empezar por el principio.
Vamos con ello.
Pero antes, ¿te has parado a pensar en lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar Surfshark?
Lo primero de todo, y más importante, es la
seguridad en la red. Con Surfshark, tu actividad
online está protegida como si fuera Fort Knox:
cifrada y a salvo de ojos curiosos que quieran
meter mano a tus datos. Además, con CleanWeb,
te despides de los anuncios y el malware. ¿Y tus
emails? Con Surfshark Alert te enteras al instante
si alguien ha intentado filtrar tu información.
Pero, ¡un momento, hay más! Surfshark
es la primera VPN comercial que tiene
servidores en más de un centenar de
países. Imagínate, es como tener un
pasaporte global a un solo click: puedes acceder
a cualquier contenido bloqueado por ubicación.
Y si te preocupa tener que elegir en qué
dispositivo usarlo, tranquilo. Con la
misma cuenta, puedes proteger todos
tus dispositivos, ya sea tu móvil,
tu tablet, la tele o el ordenador.
Y un pequeño secreto entre tú y yo:
puedes compartir la cuenta con tus colegas. Así,
entre todos, cada uno paga unos céntimos al mes.
Además por ser parte de la comunidad
VisualPolitik podrás disfrutar de 3
meses extra totalmente gratis
usando el código “POLITIK”.
Y ahora sí, arranquemos.
Busquemos todas las respuestas.
T1
(DEL IMPERIO A LA NEUTRALIDAD)
En la cultura y en la imaginación popular
siempre solemos ver a Suecia como un estado
tranquilo y moderado, un reducto de paz social y
el Sanctasanctórum de la socialdemocracia moderna.
Claro que esto no siempre fue así.
Su pasado fue mucho más… Intimidante.
El Imperio sueco fue una de las potencias europeas
más poderosas del siglo XVII. Por aquel momento
su territorio incluía también las actuales
Finlandia, Estonia y buena parte de Noruega.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué os contamos
esto en VisualPolitik? Pues porque la
configuración del territorio actual
en esta región de Europa responde
a los acontecimientos provocados por la
conocida como la “Gran Guerra del Norte”.
Hablamos de un conflicto que
entre 1700 y 1721. Durante
esos años el Imperio Sueco mantuvo
un conflicto armado contra Rusia,
Dinamarca y Noruega, precisamente,
por la supremacía en el mar Báltico.
(El conflicto terminó con el Tratado de
Nystad en 1721. Con este tratado Suecia
fue doblegada ante el zarismo ruso. Y eso
no es todo, algunas décadas más tarde,
entre los años 1808 y 1809 estalló la
conocida como “Guerra Finlandesa” donde
Rusia volvió a prevalecer sobre Suecia.
Entonces el Gran Ducado de Finlandia pasó
a estar bajo control de San Petersburgo, por
aquel entonces la capital del imperio ruso.)
Y así, de esta forma, poco a poco, Rusia se fue
convirtiendo en una gran potencia báltica. Este
mar dejó de ser una especie de lago exclusivo
del Imperio Sueco para llegar a convertirse
con el paso del tiempo en la salida natural
de la flota rusa hacia los mares del mundo.
Por su parte, Suecia, a partir del siglo XIX y
tras haber perdido su antigua grandeza imperial,
adoptó una política de neutralidad. La
reorganización del Estado y el desarrollo
del país pasaron a ser sus grandes prioridades.
Hablamos de una neutralidad que durante más de 150
años prácticamente solo fue puesta en cuestión
durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial. Puesta en
cuestión que no rota. Formalmente, Suecia
no se adhirió a ninguno de los dos bandos.
Y, más tarde, en 1949, cuando la II Guerra
Mundial ya había dado paso a la Guerra Fría,
Estocolmo optó por mantenerse
fuera de la OTAN y declarar
una política de seguridad basada en
la independencia y la neutralidad.
(Con todo, en los 90 llegó a Suecia una ola
de entusiasmo europeísta, de tal forma que en
1995 este país decidió finalmente romper con su
histórica política de Estado e integrarse en la
Unión Europea. Además, aunque se mantuvo fuera
de la OTAN sí que reforzó sus lazos con esta
organización. Por ejemplo, durante todos
estos años ha participado como “afiliado”,
como “aliado” y no como miembro en misiones de
la OTAN en Bosnia, Kosovo, Afganistán y Libia.)
Y eso no es todo. En 2007 Suecia se unió
a Finlandia, Noruega, Estonia, Irlanda,
Letonia y Lituania dentro del Grupo de combate
Nórdico (NBG), uno de los Grupos de combate
de la Unión Europea, cuyo cuartel general
está, precisamente, en la localidad sueca
de Enköping. Desde allí se dirige un grupo de
reserva de 2.400 soldados de dichos países.
Es decir, que la neutralidad sueca comenzó a
desaparecer a toda velocidad. Algo que, podéis
creernos, a Vladímir Putin no le hizo ninguna. Y
os preguntaréis, ¿qué hizo el líder ruso? Pues,
básicamente, hacer lo que mejor sabe hacer: poner
en marcha una campaña constante de intimidación.
¿Su objetivo? Evitar a toda costa que Suecia
decidiera unirse a la Alianza Atlántica.
N3 (11 de septiembre de 2014: Acciones militares
rusas en el Báltico "sin precedentes". El ministro
de Defensa polaco, Tomasz Siemoniak, dijo que
la mayor parte de la actividad se produjo en
aguas y espacios aéreos internacionales y
que Suecia fue el país más afectado. BBC)
N4 (24 de marzo de 2015: Suecia intercepta
aviones militares rusos que vuelan con
sus transpondedores apagados sobre la
región del Báltico. Business Insider)
N5 (26 de octubre de 2016: Rusia refuerza
la Flota Báltica en medio de las tensiones
de la OTAN. El ministro de Defensa
de Suecia dijo que su país estaba
preocupado por la presencia de los
buques de guerra en el Mar Báltico,
y se quejó de que la medida probablemente
mantendría alta la tensión en la región. Reuters)
Pero, ¿por qué le importa tanto a Rusia lo que
puedan hacer países como Finlandia o Suecia? Lo
vamos a ver en un momento en este mismo vídeo,
y ya os adelantó que las implicaciones de la
adhesión de Suecia y Finlandia son mucho
más grandes de lo que podríamos imaginar.
Pero por ahora, lo que tenemos que tener claro
es que la estrategia rusa no ha funcionado.
La invasión de Ucrania desató consecuencias
inesperadas para Rusia. Si el objetivo del
Kremlin era dar un golpe en la mesa, al final, el
miedo a la irracionalidad del oso ruso hizo que
tanto Finlandia como Suecia entendieran que todo
eso de la neutralidad e ir por libre ya no era
una opción. Formar parte de la OTAN era la
única vía real para garantizar su seguridad.
¿Y sabéis qué? Como decimos
por aquí: Dicho y hecho.
En las bases de Helsinki ya ondea la bandera de
la OTAN. Pronto lo hará también en las de Suecia,
pero, ¿por qué se ha demorado
tanto la adhesión de este país?
Pues básicamente porque había cuentas
pendientes. ¿De qué estamos hablando
exactamente? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2 (ESCOLLOS EN EL CAMINO)
Queridos amigos, para que un
país pueda adherirse a la OTAN,
todos sus miembros tienen que estar
de acuerdo y dar su visto bueno.
Eso con Finlandia fue relativamente fácil,
pero en el caso de Suecia… Bueno, digamos que
2 países miembros de la OTAN se empeñaron
en que las cosas no fueran tan sencillas.
El primer país ha sido la Turquía de Erdoğan.
Durante meses, el gobierno turco ha denunciado
que Suecia respaldaba y daba cobijo a los
militantes de organizaciones kurdas que
el gobierno turco considera grupos
terroristas y enemigos del Estado.
Además, hasta septiembre de 2022, Suecia,
también, mantenía un embargo a la venta de
armas contra Turquía por las operaciones
de este país en el norte de Siria.
Y claro, con esos dos precedentes… Estaba claro
que las negociaciones no
iban a ser coser y cantar.
Con todo, el 11 de septiembre de 2022,
se produjo un cambio de color político
en Suecia. El gobierno pasó de los
socialdemócratas a una coalición de
partidos conservadores. Un cambio
que facilitó que se aprobara una
nueva ley antiterrorista que entre otras cosas
limitaba el respaldo sueco a la causa kurda.
Más tarde, en octubre, se reunieron delegados
de los ministerios de Justicia de Suecia y de
Turquía para tratar algunas posibles
extradiciones reclamadas por Ankara.
De esta forma, pese a los históricos roces,
todo parecía ir viento en popa… Y así fue
hasta que en enero de 2023, todo saltó,
otra vez más, por los aires. Entonces un
activista danés protestó en el exterior de
la embajada turca en Estocolmo y quemó un
ejemplar del Corán. Esto provocó importantes
protestas en muchos países árabes y desató la
ira del gobierno de Erdogán. Fijaos.
Claro que hay quien dice que todo
esto no era más que una especie de
teatrillo de segunda. De esta forma,
la negativa de Turquía durante todo este tiempo
a la adhesión de Suecia podría haber respondido
no solo a las malas relaciones de Ankara con
Estocolmo, sino sobre todo con Washington.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien. Con Washington.
Y es que veréis, me explico. Las relaciones
entre Estados Unidos y Turquía llevan años
siendo bastante malas. Y de hecho, el
presidente Biden ha tenido sobre la mesa
durante meses varios paquetes de venta de
armas a Turquía pendientes de aprobación.
Entre ellos la venta de aviones
de F-16 de última generación.
Y como Estados Unidos estaba como loco con que
Suecia entrara de una vez por todas a la OTAN,
Turquía puede haber aprovechado la
ocasión para presionar al Tío Sam.
N8 (11 julio 2023: EE. UU. Despeja el camino
para las ventas de F-16 a Turquía en medio de
la expansión de la OTAN. WSJ)
La pregunta es, ¿Se ha salido
con la suya? Pues… El tiempo nos dirá.
Luego el otro país que también ha entorpecido
la integración de Suecia ha sido… Hungría.
[Erdogan y Orban, vaya tándem.]
El caso es que, en el marco de la Unión
Europea, Suecia es prácticamente la
antítesis de Hungría en prácticamente todo:
desde la inmigración, a las políticas LGTBI,
pasando por la política social y ambiental o
la posición respecto a la guerra de Ucrania.
N6 (5 de octubre de 2016: Suecia
amenaza con demandar a Hungría por
denegación de asilo. El ministro de
Justicia de Suecia, Morgan Johansson,
dijo que Suecia desafiará a Hungría en
los tribunales a menos que comience a
aceptar a solicitantes de asilo de
otros países de la UE. Euobserver)
N7 (20 de febrero de 2019: Las relaciones
entre Suecia y Hungría se congelan a medida
que aumenta la disputa diplomática. La ministra
socialdemócrata de Asuntos Sociales de Suecia,
Annika Strandhäll, escribió en Twitter que
la política de planificación familiar de
siete puntos del primer ministro Viktor
Orban "apesta a la década de 1930" y que
"lo que está sucediendo en Hungría es alarmante".
TheLocal)
Sea como sea, al final, Suecia entrará en la OTAN.
Y la pregunta, la pregunta más importante de todas
y que aún tenemos pendiente de responder, es:
¿Por qué demonios es tan importante para la OTAN
la adhesión de dos países relativamente poco
poblados como Suecia y como Finlandia? ¿Por qué
decimos que esto supone un enorme varapalo para
los intereses de Rusia? ¿Por qué durante años
Moscú quiso evitar a toda costa este escenario?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3 (LA ÚLTIMA PIEZA DEL ROMPECABEZAS)
Fijaos en lo que decía en 2016 un informe del
Centro Internacional de Defensa
y Seguridad con sede en Estonia.
C2 (Sin [Suecia y Finlandia] en la OTAN,
la Alianza carece de profundidad
estratégica y operativa en la región,
y también de capacidad suficiente para ejercer
un mayor control sobre el espacio marítimo y
aéreo en el mar Báltico. Si Rusia consiguiera
obligar a Estocolmo y Helsinki a mantenerse al
margen de un conflicto en el Báltico, las
opciones de respuesta de la OTAN se verían
aún más limitadas. Closing NATO’s Baltic Gap,
International Centre for Defence and Security)
Pero, ¿por qué es tan importante que Suecia y
Finlandia se integren en la OTAN? Pues bien,
la respuesta la podéis ver
claramente en este mapa:
(Tras la anexión de Crimea en 2014,
Estados Unidos realizó una variedad
juegos de guerra para buscar debilidades
estratégicas en las fronteras de la OTAN.
Estos juegos mostraron que la isla
sueca de Gotland jugaría un papel
clave en el caso hipotético de tener
que defender las repúblicas bálticas.
Si llegado el caso, Rusia cortara el corredor
de Suwalki ((Marcar en el mapa) y se apoderara
de Gotland para desplegar en ella sistemas de
defensa área, tal y como podéis ver en el mapa,
las repúblicas bálticas prácticamente quedarían
atrapadas. Sería muy difícil poder acudir en
su auxilio. Y ni siquiera habría que llegar
tan lejos. Con que Rusia impidiera a la OTAN
utilizar esa isla, un ataque híbrido contra los
bálticos, incluso con tropas no identificados
como ya ocurrió en Crimea, podría ser una
pesadilla para las fuerzas atlánticas. Esta es,
o mejor dicho, era una de las grandes
bazas que a largo plazo ha tenido Rusia.)
Y eso no es todo.
La integración de Finlandia y, sobre todo, de
Suecia en la OTAN también acaba con la mayor
parte del valor estratégico de Kaliningrado.
Ahora la OTAN podría llegado el caso cortar
muy fácilmente las comunicaciones entre este
territorio y el resto de Rusia. Digamos que
la flota rusa del báltico aquí desplegada deja
de tener capacidad para moverse libremente. Y
no solo eso. Llegado el caso, Rusia ni siquiera
podría hacer llegar suministros a este enclave.
Y, ojo, porque esto refuerza la idea que
tienen muchos analistas de que tarde o temprano
Kaliningrado terminará fuera de Rusia. Algo
de lo que os hablaremos muy pronto en Patreon.
Y exactamente lo mismo ocurre con la
entrada y salida de mercancías desde y
al mercado mundial. Rusia depende
en gran medida del comercio que
atraviesa el Báltico para abastecerse
y vender sus productos al resto del
mundo. Ahora esas comunicaciones estarán
supeditadas al visto bueno de la OTAN.
Y eso tampoco es todo. La capacidad
de la fuerza aérea rusa para alcanzar
posiciones en el resto de Europa
también se verá muy limitada.
En otras palabras, si durante décadas el mar
Báltico fue un mar controlado por Rusia que le
daba acceso al mismísimo corazón de Europa, a su
armada y a su fuerza área, ahora eso ha dejado de
ser así. La integración de Finlandia y de Suecia
en la OTAN ha cortado de raíz esa posibilidad.
De hecho, la OTAN, Finlandia y Estonia ya
han anunciado ambiciosos planes para tener
la capacidad de cerrar, llegado el caso, el
golfo de Finlandia ((Destacar en el mapa)).
Asimismo, en 2022, Rusia anunció
planes para reconstruir su poder
marítimo en la zona. Ahora
esos planes son papel mojado.
C3 (“Con la entrada de Suecia y Finlandia en la
OTAN, el mar Báltico quedará rodeado por Estados
miembros de la OTAN. El objetivo de establecer el
poder marítimo ruso, proclamado de nuevo en 2022
con la publicación de la nueva doctrina naval
rusa, sería ahora inviable en esta región de
importancia estratégica”. The German Institute
for International and Security Affairs (SWP))
Y si la flota báltica de Rusia con todo esto es
prácticamente historia, la futura integración de
Ucrania en la OTAN hará que ocurra lo mismo con
la Flota del Mar Negro, pero ese es otro asunto.
Siguiendo con Suecia, aunque este país
tiene un ejército relativamente pequeño,
aporta a la alianza una importante industria
militar. Y, ojo, porque las fábricas suecas
producen no solo armas pequeñas, sino sistemas
avanzados como aviones de combate, misiles,
tanques, submarinos, corbetas
y plataformas de defensa aérea.
C4 ("Creemos que vamos a contribuir a la
defensa de los Aliados. No tenemos unas
Fuerzas Armadas tan numerosas como Finlandia,
pero contamos con las tecnologías más avanzadas
y empresas de Defensa muy potentes". Teppo
Tauriainen, embajador de Suecia en España.)
Es decir, que la adhesión de Suecia a
la OTAN supone sin exagerar uno de los
mayores saltos en términos de seguridad
para toda Europa de las últimas décadas.
La operación militar especial de Putin
logró que Rusia pasase de compartir 841
km de fronteras con la OTAN en 2021 a más de
2.100 tras la entrada de Finlandia. Ahora la
integración de Suecia le supondrá
perder también toda su influencia
en el mar Báltico. El desastre en
términos estratégicos es colosal.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti: ¿Cómo
crees que responderá Rusia a la integración de
Suecia en la OTAN? ¿Crees que el siguiente tiene
que ser lograr que Kaliningrado se separe del
resto de Rusia? Déjanos tus impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like,y
suscribiros a VisualPolitik si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK”
acabado en “K” podréis disfrutar de 3
meses extra totalmente gratis con Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.